[Musique]
en 1812 napoléon est à l'apogée de sa
gloire il domine toutes les nations
d'europe et rennes sur près de 40
millions de sujets sont au pire est
immense à l'égal de celui de césar ou
d'alexandre deux crans c'est indéniable
napoléon a su forger des grâces a les
jambes et là on voit très bien comme
disait david lui-même que c'était beau
comme l'antique le visage de napoléon ce
pouvait le simplifier si vous voulez en
quelques traits pour en faire un visage
à l'antique et donc glorifier l'empereur
au même titre qu à l'empereur romain les
cent trente départements français ces
tirs alors de la baltique à la côte
romaine et aucun pouvoir ne peut
prétendre s'élever contre son hégémonie
il est le maître absolu
qui aurait pu prédire le destin
extraordinaire de ce petit corse
entré à 15 ans à l'école royale
militaire nommé général en chef des
armées d'italie à 26 ans par le
directoire premier consul à 30 ans puis
sacré empereur des français à 35 ans
imaginons nous qu'en 25 ans de temps ce
garçon qui avait traversé l'histoire
comme une météore en 25 ans de temps il
avait bouleversé l'europe beaucoup plus
qu'elle ne l'avait été en un siècle à la
devise de la royauté à chacun selon sa
naissance il oppose sa propre devise à
chacun selon ses mérites et s'illustre
non seulement comme grand stratège
militaire mais aussi comme
administrateur de génie et préfet le
code civil
le concordat ou les lycées publics en
sont des exemples édifiants
notre troisième et dernier épisode
consacré à napoléon 1er s'ouvre sur la
dramatique campagne de russie géant
insaisissable qui décimera l'armée
française
il retrace la campagne de france qui
opposera napoléon à une coalition anti
française forte de près d'un million
d'hommes apportant son lot de morts et
de désillusions vers la perte de l'an
pire quand on pense aux champs de
bataille dévasté au nombre de morts
provoquées par la grande armée sur toute
l'europe à la ce qu'il faut bien appeler
la traces sanglantes de l'ogre ça paraît
bizarre de dire c'était un homme
sentimental romantique virgilien par
moment parce que on sait qu'il aimait
beaucoup rousseau
puis viendra le temps de l'exil
contraint de laisser la france aux mains
de louis xviii
l'empereur ne règnera plus que sur un
royaume ridicule l'île d'elbe
[Musique]
les cent jours verront le vol de l'aigle
le retour en force de l'empereur ce
second souffle de l'épopée napoléonienne
s'achèvera à waterloo
il conduira l'empereur à sainte hélène
où il terminera séjour en dictant ses
mémoires marquant assis l'histoire de
son empreinte indélébile
[Musique]
il a l'ambition il veut il veut être le
meilleur il veut être le premier
constamment constamment et même à
sainte-hélène jusqu'au dernier moment
sur son lit d'agonie
il faisait encore trembler l'humanité
bonaparte n'est point grand par ses
paroles ses discours ses écrits par
l'amour des libertés qu'il n'a jamais eu
et n'a jamais prétendu établir il est
grand surtout pour être né de lui seul
pour avoir su son autre autorité que
celle de son génie se faire obéir par 36
millions de sujets il est grand pour
avoir abattu tous les rois ses opposants
pour avoir d'effet toutes les armées et
quelques étés la différence de leur
discipline et de leurs valeurs pour
avoir rempli dix années de tel prodige
qu'on a à peine aujourd'hui à les
comprendre
chateaubriand mémoires d'outre-tombe
[Musique]
le traité de tilsit signé cinq ans plus
tôt consolider la paix entre l'empiré la
russie alexandre espère alors avec le
soutien du général caulaincourt la
signature d'un traité empêchant le
rétablissement de son ennemi la pologne
mais en désavouant caulaincourt et en
signant la paix avec l'autriche
napoléon trahi la confiance d'alexandre
qui voit la pologne comme une porte
d'entrée dangereuse vers une invasion de
son territoire
[Musique]
dans l'espoir de ruiner le royaume uni
napoléon a mis en place une politique
appelée blocus continental empêchant
l'ennemi de commercer avec le reste de
l'europe
depuis l'année 1806 le but de napoléon
et donc de détacher toute l'europe delà
de leurs orbites anglaise d'isoler les
anglais et leur particulier grâce au
blocus continental
alors évidemment l'angleterre a été bien
près d'être ruinés et donc la victoire
de napoléon aurait peut-être été
possible à plus long terme contre
l'angleterre
si effectivement les russes avaient
poursuivi le traité tilsit la levée de
ce blocus par alexandre plonge
l'empereur dans une rage noire
précipitant les deux géants dans une
guerre inévitable
le 24 juin 1812 fermement décidée à
envahir la russie napoléon franchi le
niémen avec ses troupes dans l'espoir de
ramener par la force l'allié d'hier
alexandre allard et sans les forces en
présence sont simples d'un côté il y à
l'armée russe de l'autre côté il ya tout
l'empiré français c'est à dire l'armée
française mais également l'armé du
royaume d'italie du royaume des deux
siciles c'est à dire le sud de l'italie
il y à toute l'armée du conflit de la
confédération dur dur un royaume de fès
valley de saxe de bavière tout ce que
vous voulez les hollandais les danois
également plus les alliés de la france
c'est à dire qu'il y a des couilles de
comptes de forts contingents autrichien
et prussiens
[Musique]
mais au lieu de se diriger vers la
capitale saint pétersbourg la grande
armée forte de plus de 600 milles sommes
plus nombreuses qu aucune autre armée de
l'histoire s'enfonce dans les terres de
russie sans jamais trouver d'ennemis à
combattre terre brûlée désolation
villages dévastés
napoléon semble désemparé face à la
tactique du commandant coup tout sauf
qui refuse d'abord le combat ravageant
les villages afin de priver
l'envahisseur de ravitaillement
l'entraînant dans la profondeur de sa
toile jusqu'à épuisement
on laisse les troupes au style s'avancer
le plus possible dans le pays
donc on fuit on ne livre pas de combat
défensif
et puis après on laisse ni vers faire le
reste et puis les cosaques et les
troupes qui emprisonne l'occupant et
qu'il eu la moindre hissent sur ses
flancs sur son arrière-garde et les
russes ont opéré comme ça au moment de
la campagne de russie qui est une lourde
erreur stratégique de napoléon parce
qu'il n'a pas vu le risque qu'ils
prenaient en s'avançant à l'intérieur de
la russie
trois semaines de chaleur et de
sécheresse affaiblissent
considérablement l'infanterie la
dysenterie et le manque de nourriture à
raison de beaucoup de soldats les bottes
des fantassins s'enfonce dans cette
poussière molle rendant toujours plus
difficile leur progression une
atmosphère lourde et étouffante prend
les soldats à la gorge et ne cesse pas
même la nuit de continuer à les
asphyxier on se battait pour avoir de
l'eau et on buvait même la peau tolstoï
guerre et paix
le 14 août 1812 la grande armée
française traverse sur des ponts de
fortune construits pendant la nuit
le fleuve niépce arras n'a sous le
commandement de murat nez et davo en
ligne de mire la ville fortifiée de
smolensk qu'il projette de prendre par
surprise afin de continuer d'avancer
vers le nord mais quand les forces
françaises arrivent sur la ville les
garnisons russes ont été renforcées
l'artillerie par des tirs ininterrompus
foudroie les faubourgs et ouvre
d'énormes brèches dans les remparts
forçant l'ennemi a incendié la ville
avant de battre en retraite
[Musique]
si la bataille de smolensk se solde par
une victoire pour napoléon les
ressources viennent vite à manquer les
russes avaient adopté la théorie de la
terre brûlée c'est à dire dès qu'il
arrivait quelque part tout était brûlé
on avait plus de vivre on est plus de
ravitaillement en deux mois napoléon
père cent cinquante mille sommes
pratiquement sans avoir échangé un seul
coup de feu
courant après cet ennemi insaisissable
qui se replient toujours plus loin à
l'intérieur du pays
quand l'armée russe se décide enfin à
l'affronter le 7 septembre 1812 sur les
bords de la moskova près du village de
borodino la bataille se transforme en
assaut frontal sanglant et bestial
elle commence à 6h30 du matin et on
entend s'effondrer les corps disloqué
dans la bo jusqu'à 3 heures de l'après
midi
les russes ne cède pas et se battre
jusqu'au bout mais comme il abandonne le
champ de bataille le lendemain napoléon
s'octroie la victoire cédant moscou
réduite à l'effrayante vision d'une
ville fantôme
désertée par ses habitants et vidé de
ses provisions que les troupes
françaises victorieuses vont entrer deux
jours plus tard avant que la cité
construite essentiellement de bois ne
s'embrase
alors il ya la polémique célèbre est ce
que c'est la grande armée qui a incendié
moscou est ce que ce sont les russes qui
l'ont incendiée rue semble bien que ce
sont les russes qui ont pratiqué la
politique de la terre brûlée de la ville
brûlé en l'occurrence c'est ce qui fait
que la prise du kremlin tout symbolique
qui a été a été bien amers les flammes
coutume moscou presque intégralement
sous les yeux stupéfaits de l'empereur
des français jusque-là persuadé de
l'imminence de la reddition russe toutes
les fictions de l' incendie de 3 jamais
né galère la réalité de celui de moscow
s'était littéralement un océan de feu
j'ai des faits des armées mais je n'ai
pas vaincu les flammes
le destin a été plus fort que moi
mémorial de sainte-hélène
c'est une une ville complètement déserté
qui s'offrent à l'empereur il va
l'occuper
mais il va chercher à traiter avec le
dard en envoyant en particulier des
émissaires à saint pétersbourg et
malheureusement le dard ne répondra
jamais et donc ils retardent il retarde
son départ jusqu'au 14 octobre 17 1812
date à laquelle il décide de retourner
en occident malheureusement il est déjà
bien tard et le froid va arriver et on
sait qu'en plus l'hiver 1812 a été
particulièrement rigoureux
l' incendie de moscou marque le début
d'une longue et difficile retraite alors
que dans l'ombre guette l'hiver glacée
qui apporte la mort griffant la chair et
brisant les os des soldats qui périssent
déjà de fin et de désespoir attaqués
sans répit par les cavaliers kozak
des milliers de soldats père de la vie
dans la seule traversée du fleuve
bérézina fait demi tour mais un peu de
retard parce que l'hiver tombe très
rapidement c'est la panique la plus
complète dans cette retraite de russie
il faut franchir le fleuve que j'appelle
la bérézina et l'expression c'est la
bérézina c'est en effet c'est à dire la
catastrophe c'est la catastrophe
pourquoi parce que les armées russes
viennent harceler les arrière-gardes
française les massacres et massacré les
chevaux que l'on mangeait lier tous cru
parce qu'on n'avait plus rien à se
mettre sous la dent
[Musique]
napoléon n'est que deux témoins
impuissants de ce drame qui décime
chaque jour davantage sassi grande armée
alors pendant qu'il napoléon se prépare
à revenir de russie eh bien il existe à
paris 1
un petit général général qui a de
l'ambition puisque il envisage tout
simplement de prendre le pouvoir et le
dit l'empereur est loin je prend le
pouvoir il annonce que à paris que
l'empereur est mort à moscou et que lui
va s'occuper du nouveau gouvernement le
5 décembre 1812 l'empereur apprend que
le général mallet a osé tenté un coup
d'état contre lui il décide de rentrer à
paris
et confie le commandement de son arme
est plus que jamais en déroute à murat
c'est une grande armée en lambeaux qui
franchit le niémen en prusse orientale
le 14 décembre 1812 napoléon reviendra
sur cette défaite lors de son exil à
sainte hélène
on peut s'empêcher de frémir à l'idée
d'une telle masse qui déborde impunément
sur vous inondent en tout si elle
triomphe ou se retirer au milieu des
glaces au sein de la désolation de la
mort devenus ses réserves
n'est ce pas là la tête de l'hydre dont
on ne saurait venir à bout quand le
saisissant au corps et en l'étouffant
dans ses bras
mais où trouver recul il n'appartenait
qu'à nos doses et y prétendre et nous
l'avons tenté gauchement il faut en
convenir mémorial de sainte-hélène
on a de très très grands généraux
gleeson le comme le général et blé ou le
général lariboisière ce sont eux qui ont
construit les ponts sur la bérézina qui
sont également morts le 31 décembre 1812
de tes efforts qu'ils avaient fait des
hommes d'état avait un qui sont revenus
à pied de russie comme le maréchal
lefebvre dans les châles lefebvre homme
de 57 ans qui est revenu à pied de
moscou donc des surhommes d'une certaine
façon cette campagne militaire reste un
indicible désastre moins de dix mille
hommes sur six cent mille ans
reviendront en vie
[Musique]
entendant les râles et l'essoufflement
de l'armée française les rois de prusse
d'autriche d'espagne du portugal et de
suède voit une occasion unique de se
libérer du joug de l' empire et
reprennent les armes en s'alliant à la
russie et à la grande bretagne
à ce moment là même les français sont
lassés de leur empereur la brutalité de
la guerre en espagne et l'invasion de la
russie ont anéanti une génération
entière d'hommes en 1813
l'europe devient de théâtre de nouveaux
affrontements la coalition anti
française forte d'un million d'hommes
combat pour libérer l'allemagne et
restaurer les anciennes monarchies
elle est conduite par blücher le
prochain qui est napoléon depuis que ce
dernier l'a écrasée est fait prisonnier
à iéna schwarzenberg issu d'une longue
lignée de prince du saint-empire romain
germanique et bernadotte ancien ministre
de la guerre sous le directoire est
alliée de l'empereur
face à eux les trois cent soixante mille
français de la nouvelle armée levé par
napoléon pour renforcer ses rangs
l'empereur fait appel par décret
anticipation aux jeunes conscrits les
marie-louise novice dans l'art de la
guerre et ignorant le maniement des
armes
on se le cacher on ne voulait pas entrer
dans l'armée
malgré la conscription et pour essayer
d'être réformé on se couper les doigts
on se on se casser les dents parce que
fait qu'on avait besoin des danses avec
les dents soit intacte pour enlever la
goupille de la cartouche etc si on n'est
plus dans ne pouvait pas se défendre
l'opposition gronde alimentant la
légende noire de napoléon
ce n'était pas tous d'enchaîner les
pères il fallait encore disposer des
enfants on en était venu à ce point de
mépris pour la vie des hommes et pour la
france
d'appeler les conscrits la matière
première ou la chair à canon
chateaubriand de bonaparte et des
bourbons la bataille de leipzig tourne
rapidement à l'avantagé des coalisés
napoléon ordonne la retraite de ses
troupes qui doivent traverser la rivière
elster pourvoir à leur grande surprise
leurs alliés sacs sont retournés contre
eux leur a retiré le premier mois de la
campagne de france est marquée par
l'avancée lente mais constante des
troupes coalisées l'armée française
commandée par victor défendant les
vosges et bas rebonds défendant la sarre
recule devant l'armée de buchères de
même que né évacue nancy les autrichiens
n'ont porte en italie les britanniques
repousse tous les maréchaux hors
d'espagne pour les combattre ensuite
dans le sud de la france
pendant ce temps à paris talleyrand
compagnons d'hier perçu par certains
comme un traître et par d'autres comme
un visionnaire de génie
talleyrand attise la haine contre
napoléon et les alliés d'hier change de
camp alors ta laurent est un personnage
extrêmement
compliqué à comprendre c'est un homme
extrêmement intelligent c'est un ancien
évêque l'évêque d'autun
à la veille de la révolution il est
député du clergé à la au début des états
généraux donc en 1789
par la suite il va un peu disparaître il
va réapparaître au moment de l' empire
en particulier napoléon fera son
ministre des affaires étrangères mais
c'est un homme de l'ancien régime un
homme du xviiie siècle qui n'a jamais
abandonné les comptes ses convictions
que qui tire beaucoup de ficelles dans
l'ombre et qui est pas toujours bien
d'accord avec napoléon napoléon dira de
lui vous êtes de la boue dans un vote
soit le 11 janvier 1814 une alliance est
conclu entre murat roi de naples et
l'autriche
il promet de fournir trente mille hommes
à la coalition pour garantir la
pérennité de son trône paralysant ainsi
l'armée d'italie commandé par eugène de
beauharnais peu à peu lent pire se
délite ne possédant plus que l'ombre de
sa gloire passée
napoléon déclare au sénat qu'il s'agit à
présent de défendre la france contre
l'envahisseur plus cher s'apprête à
opérer la jonction avec l'armée de
zwartberg dans les plaines de l'aube
quand napoléon décide commandes et lui
même sont armés ils confient la régence
à l'impératrice marie louise et son fils
le roi de rome à la garde nationale
avant de quitter paris
il se jette comment lyon coeur de la
bataille de brienne le 29 janvier 1814
et s'en sort avec des pertes égale à
celle de ccnb
ils accèdent ensuite de combattre à la
rothière avec une armée affaiblie
inférieure en nombre cette première
défaite sévère pèse lourdement sur le
moral des troupes françaises ait
déclenché des désertions massives
on a commencé à qualifier l'empereur
d'ogre de dévoreur de jeunes vies de
dévoreur de soldats donc les caricatures
ont couru sur ce tellement pas surtout
dans les années 1800 capteurs ou bien
entendu mais dès 1810 1811 on voit
apparaître plus de caricatures que dans
la période précédente
et au final effectivement la france est
assez exemple en 1814 le 3 février un
nouveau congrès s'ouvre à châtillon la
coalition propose la paix moyennant quoi
elle exige que la france retrouve ses
frontières de 1791 refusant qu'elle
prenne part à la réorganisation futur de
l'europe
condamnant ainsi les membres de sa
famille que l'empereur avait placé
stratégiquement sur les trônes des pays
conquis napoléon jugeant ces clauses
humiliante refuse de signer pendant ce
temps les combats continuent d'enflammer
le pays les armées de plus cher de
schwarzenberg marche sur châlons sur
marne sur trois et font dangereusement
route vers paris en suivant
respectivement les vallées de la marne
de la seine
l'étau se resserre
durant cinq jours de combats acharnés la
pole et on retrouve toute l'énergie et
l'intelligence stratégique qui
caractérisait ses premiers faits d'armes
en italie malheureusement il est déjà
trop tard
les pertes des alliés restent
insignifiantes temps leurs armées sont
puissantes et leurs ressources infinies
faut jamais oublier que c'était un
officier d'artillerie au départ c'est à
dire un homme qui calculent qu'ils
travaillent là-bas liste et qui
travaillent les emplacements et tous ces
stratégies de guerre ont été écrites
minutes et c'était vraiment quelqu'un de
très rationnel et il a été pratiquement
jusqu'au bout accumulant très souvent
des erreurs par par excès de rationalité
[Musique]
la bataille de monte euros sera le
dernier succès de napoléon obligeant
l'ennemi a reculé alors qu'il n'est qu'à
50 km de paris mais après les dernières
batailles particulièrement meurtrière à
crâne et là on les généraux en ont assez
de se battre et la france veut la paix à
paris les français conduits par les
maréchaux marmont et mortier n'ont plus
qu'un seul objectif combattre pour
l'honneur ils savent que plus rien
n'empêchera les coalisés de forcer les
portes de la capitale
mais il ignore que l'empereur est en
marche pour tenter de la sauver
le 30 mars 1814 à l'aube
schwarzenberg attaque paris par pantin
et romainville alors que plus cher
concentre sa puissance de feu sur clichy
montmartre en serrant la capitale dans
un véritable et de mons est commandant
de la garde nationale défend avec ardeur
la barrière de clichy dans un
affrontement des plus sanglants la ville
agonise dans un tonnerre assourdissant
de tirs d'artillerie et de cris de
douleur des soldats le sang et la poudre
se mêlent les flammes qu'annoncé par le
trou chaotique des escouades de
cavaliers en fuite
dans ce cas un étrange ballet qui
dévorent les bâtiments dans les rues
s'amoncellent décor illustres ou
inconnus aux membres arrachés à la
tombée de la nuit dans un dernier
souffle
paris succombe
chacun ramasser morts l'armée française
perd 6000 hommes et inflige trois fois
plus de pertes aux coalisés sans faire
de prisonniers
[Musique]
c'était la période la plus féconde en
matière d'imagination militaire et c'est
pour ça que cette période est toujours
enseigné dans toutes les écoles
d'officiers du monde
les négociations sont ouvertes
talleyrand en est le médiateur marmont
et mortiers signer un armistice pour une
durée de quatre heures le temps pour
l'armée française d'évacuer la capitale
napoléon est à juvisy sur orge lorsque
la nouvelle sonne comme un coup de
poignard
le 31 mars à 7 heures les armées alliées
prennent le contrôle des barrières de
paris vers 10 heures des vive le roi
résonne dans les rues désertes alors que
sur la place louis 15 les royalistes
lise la proclamation de choiseul berg
aux habitants de paris exhortant le
peuple à se soulever contre napoléon
plus tard le tsar alexandre reçoit les
clés de la ville de la main même des
maires d'arrondissement la fanfare ur le
désir de conquête à la porte saint
martin pour accueillir la marche
triomphale ouverte par les cosaques
russes et les hussards prussiens
napoléon est à terre ses ennemis ont
forcé les portes de paris
ses fidèles maréchaux née lefebvre
berthier oudinot mons et mcdonald's
refusent de combattre dans un ultime
effort désespéré il fait marcher ses
dernières troupes commandées par marc
bond vers paris mais ce dernier bien
vite contraint de se rendre aux
autrichiens
[Musique]
alors napoléon est battu mais qui va
diriger le pays
eh bien on décide d'appeler à
l'unanimité ou presque
le frère cadet de louis saez qui avait
été lui exécuté et ce frère cadet c'est
louis xviii et louis xviii ravi parce
qu'il n'attendait que ça depuis
l'exécution de son frère il n'attendait
que de reprendre le pouvoir de restaurer
la monarchie en france louis xviii sa
personnalité c'est un c'est un
personnage louvoyant cette averse à ce
brillant intelligent mais louvoyant qui
a toujours essayé de faire ces petits
coups en douce même du vivant de louis
saez
il envisageait de prendre la régence
le sénat organise un gouvernement
provisoire présidé par talleyrand fins
politiques qui aura su se maintenir au
gré des changements de régime de la
révolution française à la monarchie de
juillet
[Musique]
e
le sénat déclare napoléon déchu du trône
son droit d'hérédité abolie et le peuple
français comme l'armée délié envers lui
du serment de fidélité
[Musique]
le 4 avril par arrêt du gouvernement
provisoire
il est permis aux conscrits de retourner
chez eux
[Musique]
privé de son rêve impérial bonaparte est
déterminé à disparaître avec lui on sait
la bataille de france l'a anéanti il
arrive il se réfugie à fontainebleau
avec le lendemain ou le surlendemain la
fameuse scène des adieux mais le soir ou
dans la nuit
eh bien oui les prix l'un comme on
dirait aujourd'hui d'un d'un grand coup
de cafard d'un grand coude désespoir et
il avait sur lui de l'opium et inaugure
gîte forte dose d'opium dans l'espoir
tout simplement de mettre fin à ses
jours
finalement l'empereur déchu survie pour
signer le traité de fontainebleau qui le
condamne à l'exil dressant son
abdication sans condition le 6 avril
1814 les puissants alliés ayant proclamé
que l'empereur napoléon était le seul
obstacle au rétablissement de la paix en
europe
l'empereur napoléon fidèle à son serment
déclarent qu'ils renoncent pour lui et
ses héritiers au couronne de france et
d'italie et qu'ils n'aient aucun
sacrifice personnel même celui de la vie
qu'ils ne soient prêtes à faire à
l'intérêt de la france
[Musique]
cependant une question cruciale se pose
ou enfermés intel stratège le choix des
alliés se porte sur l'île d'elbe
napoléon devient empereur qui règne sur
une île
[Musique]
le sénat appelle à gouverner le très
impopulaire louis stanislas xavier de
bourbon alors réfugié en angleterre
frère de louis saez comme roi des
français selon le voeu de la nation sous
le nom de louis xviii
il devient le nouveau roi de france
le 20 avril avant de partir pour l'île
d'elbe napoléon rend un dernier hommage
à sa garde personnelle
puis il prend la route du sud escorté
par une troupe de 600 hommes sous les
huées d'un peuple en colère auquel il
avait promis la victoire et demander ton
d'efforts pour relever lempire à saint
raphaël
il embarque sur une frégate britannique
the untold l'intrépide accompagné des
commissaires alliés et de sa petite
suite dont les généraux bertrand et
drôle on lui a donné la souveraineté on
le donnait à territoire c'était c'était
une période c'était un exil relativement
doux avec un climat qui est rappelée
complètement celui de la corse
il était relativement bien traités à
cette époque le navire entre dans la
rade portoferraio le 3 mai au soir après
avoir hissé le pavillon parlementaire
napoléon découvre alors son nouvel
empire qui s'étend sur une superficie
ridicule 223 kilomètres carrés bild
allemand méditerranée quelques ce qu'il
appelait un petit car elle joue parce
que c'est une toute petite île on avait
vite on a vite fait le tour lui qui est
habitué à sillonner l'europe est bien là
il a rapidement fait le tour de la
petite île d'elbe et bien sûrs soit sa
soeur ils reçoivent la petite marie
valeska qu'il avait beaucoup aimé à
laquelle il avait fait un fils elle
vient lui tenir compagnie pendant
quelques nuits à portoferraio
[Musique]
pendant les dix mois qu'il passe sur
l'île ils se comportent en
administrateur il s'intéresse à
l'exploitation de ses mines de fer fait
tracer des routes planter des arbres
développe l'économie et passent des
accords commerciaux avec ses voisins
il fait décorer des appartements pour
l'impératrice marie louise est son
héritier légitime qui ne le rejoindront
jamais mais napoléon se lasse vite de
jouer sur un si petit terrain et ne
cesse de diriger son regard vers la
france convaincu que le peuple ne
supportera pas le retour imposé de la
monarchie il observe guette attendant
patiemment son heure
c'est un appelé ont qui veut qu'il pense
qu'il va revenir d'une façon ou d'une
autre en france et au pouvoir malgré son
accablement de 1814 il sait que il est
sur l'île d'elbe pour peu de temps et
surtout il veut il n'a rien perdu de son
hyperactivité
louis xviii de son côté freine le
versement de la rente de 2 millions de
francs prévus par le traité de
fontainebleau
au congrès de vienne les appétits des
vainqueurs chargé de rétablir la paix en
europe s'affrontent
il s'interroge sur la possibilité d'un
retour en force de l'empereur déchu
la menace pourrait elle venir de naples
en débarquant en italie en s'alliant à
murat ne risque-t-il pas de reformer une
armée qui plongerait bientôt l'europe
entière dans un nouveau conflit
on parle alors de l'exil et aux açores
ou sur l'île de sainte hélène
tall rand a quand même une haute opinion
de la france et c'est lui en 1814 au
congrès de vienne qui va sauver la
france de la langue de la destruction
qu'avaient envisagé les alliés c'est à
dire un dépaysement total de la france
et grâce à lui bien sûr la france va
perdre la confédération durant le
royaume d'italie tous les états
satellites naturellement mais en même
temps c'est lui qui va obtenir que l'on
revienne aux frontières de l'ancien
régime celle de 1789 mais fidèle à sa
stratégie militaire
napoléon décide de partir à l'attack le
premier dans le plus grand secret il
prépare son retour
nous sommes en février 1815 et louis
joseph marchand premier valet de chambre
de l'empereur note dans ses mémoires
depuis quelques jours l'empereur dans
son intérieur était silencieux et
réfléchi le général bertrand est le
général drouot appeler beaucoup plus
fréquemment que de coutume le général
cambronne ne fut aussi la carte de
france restait constamment étendu dans
le cabinet des épingles y était piqué le
16 février 1815 napoléon ordonna drouot
de réarmer le bric l'inconstant sur ses
ordres on achète des munitions de guerre
à naples des armes à alger des vaisseaux
de transport à chaîne dix jours plus
tard à la tombée de la nuit
l'esprit embué par de nouveaux rêves de
conquête il s'embarque avec une poignée
de fidèles 11 cents hommes dont six ans
de sa garde
cap sur la france
[Musique]
le 1er mars 1815 en plein jour sous les
yeux ébahis des douaniers napoléon
débarque à golfe juan
désormais il n'y a plus que l'armée
royale qui le sépare de paris est très
rapidement sans un obstacle ou
pratiquement pas parce que le roi louis
xviii
envoi des armées à sa rencontre
notamment une armée commandée par le
maréchal mais l'ancien complice de
napoléon et bien le maréchal mais en
rencontrant l'empereur va lui tomber
dans les bras et ça va être comme ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle le vol de l'aigle
c'est à dire de golfe juan à paris ça va
être comme ça d'un bout à l'autre
à chaque fois que l'empereur apparaît
tout le monde se rallie une fois encore
à lui parce que c'est le personnage le
plus légendaire qui soit dès son retour
il réorganise son armée de deux cent
mille âmes et restitue au régiment les
surnoms d'invincible de terribles
d'incomparables cambronne qui commandent
l'avant-garde est sommé de ne tirer
aucun coup de feu afin que la surprise
demeure totale
[Musique]
six jours plus tard un régiment
d'infanterie se présente pour barrer la
route à napoléon dans la bien nommée par
stendhal prairie de la rencontre le chef
savant seul au devant de l'armée royale
en ouvrant sa redingote écrit soldats du
cinquième
reconnaissez votre empereur s'il en est
un qui veut me tuer voilà les soldats se
rallient unanimement aux cris de vive
l'empereur
ce retour en force ressoude la coalition
deux armées anglaises et prussiennes
prennent position en belgique faisant
route vers la france à marche forcée
l'empereur et dictent les premiers
décret et demande à marie louise de le
rejoindre à paris à mesure qu il galope
vers la capitale l'armée abandonne le
roi qui fuient vers beauvais escorté par
le maréchal marmont et le duc de berry
nous sommes le 20 mars 1815 napoléon
entre dans paris mais les forces
coalisées vont tout faire pour l'arrêter
afin de grossir les rangs de son armée
et de s'assurer du soutien et de la
bénédiction du peuple
napoléon réveil l'ardeur et la bravoure
de ses soldats il ranime le souvenir des
grandes victoires passées la supériorité
de la france sur des ennemis qu'à la
tante fois écrasé et pointe d'un air
grave les danger imminent qui menace le
pays
les cent jours par exemple on l'on
transformé il a rencontré benjamin
constant il prépare un acte additionnel
à la constitution il a beaucoup réfléchi
à l'île d'elbe et donc il veut montrer
sa puissance militaire mais quelque
sorte une dernière fois en grand
stratège il calcule qu'il faudra deux
jours aux armées anglaises et
prussiennes pour opérer leur jonction
entre bruxelles et namur
c'est le moment idéal il n'y a plus une
minute à perdre
il attaque par surprise les prussiens
conduit par plus cher et parvient à
prendre charleroi les brigades de
cavalerie et lagarde franchissent la
sambre pour bivouaquer entre les deux
armées ennemies
l'objectif étant de les combattre
séparément et de les vaincre avant
l'arrivée des autrichiens et des russes
l'empereur confie le commandement de
l'ale gauche de son armée au maréchal
ney qui doit s'emparer du carrefour des
quatre bras ou le redouté wellington son
unité de 7000 hommes l'attendent
wellington aristocrate anglo irlandais
et maréchal est notamment connu pour ses
victoires contre l' empire à orthez
vitoria et toulouse est il deviendra
plus tard premier ministre du royaume
uni
[Musique]
le 16 juin 1815
la bataille fait rage pour contenir des
britanniques alors que sur l'autre flanc
à ligny napoléon repousse les prussiens
ce sera la dernière victoire française
après des combats féroces les coalisés
parviennent à se replier sans être
poursuivi par les troupes napoléoniennes
le maréchal buchères échappe quant à lui
miraculeusement à la capture son cheval
atteint par un tir s'écroule sur lui et
le paralyse
alors que les grenadiers français
approche dangereusement mais la moiteur
de la nuit le camoufle jusqu'à ce que
son aide de camps parviennent à le
délivrer à une dizaine de kilomètres au
sud une autre bataille se prépare
waterloo pour la bataille de waterloo
c'est vraiment en juin 1815 le j'allais
dire le dernier coup d'esbrouffe de
l'empereur parce que il a réussi encore
à remettre sur pied une armée mais les
coalisés sont de plus en plus nombreux
la russie l'angleterre bien entendu tout
le monde est là et on sait que ce sera
forcément un coup d'épée dans l'eau
wellington dispose de 68 mille âmes et
peut compter sur les 72 milles de
buchères s'il parvient à réunir les deux
armées alliées wellinton aura alors une
supériorité numérique de deux contre un
qui ne laissera plus aucune chance de
succès aux français
la nuit précédant la bataille ils ne
cessent de pleuvoir et à l'aube ce 18
juin 1815
les soldats découvre un théâtre
d'opération détrempée la boue a remplacé
les champs de trèfle empêchant le
déploiement des canons les heures
s'égrènent
mais napoléon ne donne pas l'ordre
d'attaquer l'armée anglaise détient
trois fermes fortifiées défendu en poste
avancé sur le champ de bataille où mon
la sainte et pas pelote la crête du
plateau de mont-saint-jean au centre du
dispositif permettra aux unités de
s'abriter du feu de l'ennemi
la poêle et on n'a pas de temps à perdre
il sait que l'armée de plus cher se
rapproche
il doit tout miser sur une attaque
frontale massive à 11h30 du matin
l'artillerie française ouvre les
hostilités la pole et ont fait déployer
sa grande batterie de 80 canon et même
la tacc principal à l'est tout en
pilonnant sans relâche la ferme
d'hougoumont à l'ouest pour faire
diversion
[Musique]
mais l'infanterie progressent
difficilement les boulets de canon
s'enfonce dans la terre au lieu de
rebondir
wellington de vinon la manoeuvre de son
adversaire dispose habilement ses
troupes à l'abri de la crète
la tentative de prise de la ferme de
gaumont va devenir une véritable
bataille dans la bataille mobilisant
inutilement toute la journée près de
8000 hommes du prince jérôme frère de
napoléon contre seulement 2000 anglais à
13h30 les divisions d'infanterie attaque
la ferme de la haye sainte wellington
ordonne la charge de la cavalerie lourde
dont les célèbres scott grèzes les
français surpris par cette manoeuvre
sont forcés de se replier à la hâte
subissant de très lourdes pertes les
deux brigades de cavalerie attaques dans
leur élan la grande patrie française
mais elles sont écrasées par la
cavalerie napoléonienne rester en
arrière et il aurait pu emporter la
bataille de waterloo
ça a été c'est pour la première fois
l'enfilade de catastrophe ou de
contretemps à 15 heures une nouvelle
canonnade française vise à faire tomber
la haye sainte
wellington repli son centre persuadé
qu'il s'agit d'un repli général le
maréchal ney prend l'initiative
d'engager sa cavalerie il ignore alors
que l'armée anglaise ceux disposant
carré attendant patiemment l'assaut mais
multiplié les charges sans aucun soutien
d'infanterie est peu à peu ses hommes
s'écroule autour de lui
la cavalerie française et décider la
pole et on devine au loin les
silhouettes portant l'uniforme sombre de
l'armée prussienne doit-il se replier il
veut tenter une dernière fois de vaincre
les anglais avant que plus cher ne
paraisse devant lui je n'avais plus en
moi ce sentiment de succès définitif
je sentais qu'il me manquait quelque
chose
ce n'était plus cette fortune attaché à
mes pas qui se plaisait à me combler
c'était le destin sévères auxquelles
j'arrachais encore comme par force
quelques faveurs mais dont ils se
vengent est tout aussi tôt car il est
remarquable que je n'ai pas eu alors un
avantage qu'ils n'aient été
immédiatement suivi d'un revers mémorial
de sainte-hélène et n'a plus la main une
plus la chance il ya toute sorte de
contre ordre et de contretemps surtout
il décide de lancer la garde impériale
dans un ultime assaut la garde impériale
tant redoutée les braves des braves
ceux qui n'ont jamais reculé
les lignes françaises progressent au
rythme du tambour les anglais reste
fasciné devant ce spectacle étrange de
gestes mécaniques de regard menaçant la
volonté inextricable lagarde n'est plus
qu'à une quarantaine de pâques en
wellington donne l'ordre de tirer les
coups de fusil répond aux cris d homme
l'air saturé par la fumée des explosions
la confusion est à son comble les
soldats qui ne sont plus que des
silhouettes froissé et tous et agonise
le premier rang tombe comme un seul
homme dans un fracas assourdissant 400
français viennent de perdre la vie
lagarde continue à avancer mais il est
trop tard
les prussiens sont là alors pour la
première fois au cours des guerres
napoléoniennes lagarde recul la rumeur
se propage vite je tends le désarroi sur
le reste de l'armée française qui bat en
retraite après 10 heures de combats
acharnés
la pole et on a forcé d'abandonner de
prendre la fuite
face aux avant-gardes prussienne quatre
jours plus tard au palais de l'elysée
l'empereur abdique en faveur de son fils
napoléon 2
ils tentent de fuir par le port de
rochefort où l'attend de frégate prête à
lever l'ancré vers les états unis
mais son plan est découvert et il doit
négocier avec les vainqueurs
[Musique]
il est battu et cette fois ci les
coalisés tape vraiment sur la table en
disant une salle et par bosingwa pas le
remettre à proximité de la france
il faut donc l'exil et le plus loin
possible dans un endroit véritablement
inaccessible il demande l'asile au plus
constant de ses ennemis l'angleterre qui
décide de le déporter sur l'île
sainte-hélène une île du bout du monde
en plein coeur de l'océan atlantique
c'est la solitude et les vexations qui
attendent napoléon alan gold enfermé
surveiller privé de liberté dénigré par
hudson lowe le gouverneur de l'île qui
lui refuse le titre d'empereur et le
nomme simplement général bonaparte
les anglais qui ont pris la chose en
main lui ont mis à disposition si on
peut dire un geôlier que hudson lowe
levé l'herald sun love qui est un
mauvais général anglais qui en fait tu
es très consciencieux qui est on dire
une sorte de javert si vous voulez avec
jean valjean qui le suit partout qui
observe partout ce que napoléon fait
alors napoléon bien entendu de temps en
temps s'échappait du de l'espace qui lui
était consenti la mort n'est rien mais
vivre vaincu et sans gloire c'est mourir
tous les jours dira bonaparte lors de sa
captivité à sainte hélène
sentant sa fin approcher il est temps
pour l'empereur de construire la légende
qu'il laissera à la postérité
alors napoléon à sainte-hélène est
accompagné de quelques vieux fidèle et
notamment des manuels las cases qui va
passer son temps à côté de l'empereur
déchu à l'écouté et à noter à noter et à
écrire ce qu'on appelle le mémorial de
sainte-hélène
il est vrai que ma destinée se montre
rebours des autres à chute les abbesses
d'ordinaire la mienne me révèle
infiniment chaque jour me dépouille de
ma peau de tyrans de meurtriers de
féroces
mémorial de sainte-hélène atteint d'un
cancer de l'estomac
napoléon refuse l'assistance des
médecins anglais et meurt le 5 mai 1821
après huit jours d'agonie son autopsie
donne lieu à de nombreuses controverses
causés par la multitude de rapports
officiels et officieux dont pas moins de
trois diamétralement opposé pour le seul
docteur auto marchi qu'il a pratiqué le
coeur et l'estomac de l'empereur sont
retirés et placés dans des coupes en
argent contenant de l'esprit de 20 son
corps est revêtu de l'uniforme des
chasseurs à cheval de la garde impériale
est placé sur le lit de fer qui
l'emportait dans ses campagnes
[Musique]
napoléon laisse une france ruinée et à
l'agonie depuis 1792 elle a perdu
environ 1 million 700 mille de ces
hommes dont la majorité pendant les
guerres napoléoniennes
il ya des milliers de morts des milliers
de morts et il va falloir des deux ou
trois ou quatre voire quatre générations
avant que la france ne se sortent cette
saignée véritable saignée en 1914 on
payait encore les conséquences
démographiques du premier empire
[Musique]
les ports et ses arsenaux sont détruits
le territoire est lourdement amputé
sans compter qu'il est désormais occupée
par les coalisés
la france doit en outre s'acquitter dans
lourd tribut pour l'entretien de ses
troupes d'occupation le pays a perdu
toutes ses colonies héritées de l'ancien
régime et son influence internationale
qui s'est minutieusement depuis le règne
de louis xiv est réduite à néant
c'est une france qu'il faut entièrement
reconstruire lorsque napoléon part donc
en 1814 1815 si vous voulez
malheureusement les bourbons ne seront
pas la remettre sur pied d'autant plus
que quinze ans de révolution et d'empyr
font que les français n'acceptent plus
la monarchie et en particulier les
monarchies absolues l'empereur dans son
épopée européenne flamboyante tout en se
réclamant du droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes a paradoxalement
soumis l'europe d'une main de fer mais
par ses nombreuses réformes notamment
administratives
il a aussi insuffler une nouvelle
ambition et par là même changer la face
du monde
chateaubriand oscillant toujours entre
admiration et horreur lorsqu'il s'agit
de ce personnage double kent à pau léon
bonaparte admettra dans ses mémoires
d'outre-tombe que l'héritage de
l'empereur qu on le vénère ou qu'on le
condamne et bien réel bonaparte
appartenait si fort à la domination
absolue qui après avoir subi le
despotisme de sa personne
il nous faut subir le despotisme de sa
mémoire car si l'on combattit
quelquefois napoléon alors qu'il était
sur le trône
il y as consentement universel à
accepter les faire que mort il nous
jette